we're gonna break a rule we're breaking
one of the rules of number five we're
talking about something that isn't a
number we're gonna talk about infinity
so infinity
now
like i said infinity is not a number
right it's a idea it's a concept it's
the idea of being
endless of going on forever i think
everyone's familiar with the idea of
infinity even kids you start counting
one two three four five you know you
might be five years old but already
you're thinking what's the biggest
number i can think of
and you go oh it's 20. you get a bit old
you get maybe it's a million it never
ends does it because you can keep adding
one so that's the idea of infinity the
numbers go on forever
but i'm going to tell you one of the
more surprising facts about infinity
there are different kinds of infinity
some infinities are bigger than others
let's have a look first time of infinity
oh it's called countable and i don't
like the name countable and i brady gave
me a little bit of just then because if
you're talking about infinity you can't
count infinity can you because it goes
on forever it i think it's a terrible
name
i prefer to call it listable can we list
these numbers all right let's do the
simple numbers
one
two
three i'm not gonna do all of my jobs
how long have we got
10 minutes all right
five
six
so you can list the whole numbers so
this this is called countable list of
all i prefer
what about
the integers all the integers that's all
the negative numbers as well so there's
zero let's have that uh but there's one
a minus one there's two and minus two
there's three and minus three now that
is an infinity as well and in some sense
it's twice as big
because there seems to be twice as many
numbers
but it is infinity as well they're both
infinity and they're both the same type
of infinity they both can be
listed perhaps more surprisingly the
fractions can be listed as well but you
have to be a bit clever about this let's
try and list the fractions i'm going to
write out a rectangle 1 divided by 1.
that's a fraction that's allowed let's
have 1 divided by two
one third
one fourth
one seventh okay that goes on let's do
the next row and have two at the top two
over one two over two
two over three
two over four let's do the next one
three over one
we have a two
four over six
four over seven that goes on and we can
keep going so here i've made some sort
of infinite rectangle array of fractions
now
if i want to make a list like this
though
if i just if i went row by row you're
gonna have a problem
if you go row by row i'll go this
there's one half third fourth fifth
sixth seventh i'll keep going forever
and i'm never going to reach the second
row i can't list them not that way you
can't list them that way you'll never
reach the second row this is how you
list them slightly more clever than that
you take the diagonal lines
now i can guarantee that every fraction
will appear on one of those diagonal
lines and you list them diagonal by
diagonal so that's the first diagonal
then you list the second diagonal there
it is then you list the third diagonal
then you take the fourth diagonal and
the fifth so eventually you are going to
list every fraction every fraction
appears on a diagonal and you're going
to list them now if you take
all the numbers right so that's the
whole number line let's try that though
i'm going to draw it's a continuous line
of numbers these are all your decimals
you've got 0 there in the middle and
you'll get 1 and 2 and 3 but it has a
third
it will contain pi
and e and all the irrational numbers as
well
can you list them how do you list them
zero to start with and then
one but hang on we missed a half
so we put in a half hang on we've missed
a quarter we're putting a quarter
we've missed not .237 so if how do you
list the real numbers it turns out you
can't
and in fact and rather remarkably i can
show you that we can't list them even
though we're talking about something so
complicated as infinity
do it man we'll need paper we need to
put an amount of paper here i think
it's a big topic imagine
we could list all the decimals right we
can't actually but pretend we can what
sort of what would it look like
we'll start with all the zero point
decimals let's pick some decimals one
two one
dot dot dot dot let's pick the next one
let's say the next one is two two one
next one
uh three one one one one one two
nine and let's take another one here uh
zero zero one
seven six now i'm gonna
make a number this is the number i'm
going to make i'm going to take
the diagonals here i'm going to take
this number
and this number
and this number this number and this
number
okay and i am going to
write that down so what's that number
i've made it's not point
one two
one zero one something something
something
now this is my rule
i'm gonna make a whole new number from
that one
this is the number i'm going to make if
it has a 1
i'm going to change it to a 2
and
if it has a 2
or anything else
i will change it to a one
so let's try that
so i'm going to turn this into
not point so if it has a one i'm going
to turn it into a two if it's anything
else i'm going to turn it into a one so
that will be a one
i'm gonna change the one here into a two
i'm gonna change that one into a one i'm
going to change that one into a two
that's my rule and i make something new
that does not appear on the list
that number is completely different from
everything else on the list because it's
not the first number because it's
different in the first place
it's not the second number because it's
different in the second place
it's not the third number because it's
different in the third place it's not
the fourth number because it's different
in the fourth place it's not the fifth
number because it's different in the
fifth place you've made a number that's
not on that list and so you can't list
all the decimals in which case it is
uncountable it is unlistable and that
means it's a whole new type of infinity
a bigger type of infinity surely we
could james because all we've got to do
is keep doing your game and making them
and adding them to the list and if we
keep doing that why don't we get there
eventually uh but you could then create
another number that won't be on that
list so the guy came up with this was a
german mathematician called cantor
cantor left round about the turn of the
20th century he was ridiculed for this
for the his this idea that there are
different types of infinity
he was called a charlatan and he was
called it was nonsense it was called and
poor old cantor
uh was treated really badly by his
contemporaries and
he spent a lot of his later life uh in
and out of mental institutions uh where
in where he died and in the end near the
end of his life it was recognized it was
true it was recognized and he had all
the
recognition that he deserved and now
he's on number and now he's on number
five the greatest accolade of all
george cantor
you